em relação ao timing qual use o jogo vai
ser roubada
o lado de sua obra que fala em mudar é
preciso muito bem-vindos é mais um vídeo
e os trabalhos aqui ter fé e é bom pra
quem não sabe que eu ter raiva o rec
chupa-cabra dando muita floresta procura
pessoas pra comer eu não sei porque
nenhuma circo drec mas sei que é um
bicho estranho cair boxe diguinho e que
o livro tem um gesto que foi the world
que o bicho vai dar muita floresta e
basicamente nós temos que fugir de um ou
dois é esse jogo pela boca
bora lá ganhei nada sabem se o aumento
do volume no máximo peguei a vossa
pipoca e para lá que está o de rei
cantava fazê-lo dem as horas no dem já
fez um sorriso saudável eu adoro este
vidros olha só a cair aparentemente isto
dentro de uma casa
eu não sei o que é que isto é na haia
está o acampamento é isso o fez um só
pessoal este é o de reiki e este é o
bicho vai andar atrás nós mas por
enquanto está do dia o lyon antes que
pudessem não não eu saio do rei que só
sai à noite portanto está tudo bem
porque o estado dinheiro ainda tudo
fluiu de bonito olha que só elano e
botafogo pb a partir do próximo ano a
linha my eyes off you tube futebol clube
futebol e futebol que também atua passo
do papa pio xii não ia se é só o show
lendário que vamos lá se diz aqui embora
projeto open door
o office um só caminho lindote parece
ter renovado estela time estava ontem
que vários equipamentos coisas que não
sei para que servem o acampamento mil e
a rigor com meu deus como a cimpor
economia da floresta não dá aqui não é o
meu deus q tanque até que qualquer coisa
pra apanhar ordem um saco do filho onde
um saco com fim do ano deve ser de
educação do esporte ó não só pessoal tá
ali tahuni nosso ritmo é tal um pouco
silvestre
lá mais rápido com a que eu gastava 11
um gol assim como a que ocorre ser ainda
mais com ferrari antiga hérnias ok então
é só sentar pra mim ea zona de caça o
que quer dizer que nós não vamos por uma
então porque l1 do drag e nós não
queremos ser apanhados por um ambiente
que outro caminho o tanque com o cenário
que lembra o do not essa quebra é
preciso investir bock
eu acho que eu tenho que instalar as
câmeras para conseguir vir do ranking a
noite será isso eu não sei mas faz todo
sentido que seja sai não o povo faz
barulho saí daqui por kaká e agora é
preciso encontrar câmeras não é câmeras
de evitar que o uol o eu sou um gênio eu
sou um faq um gênio já foi dito no
twitter o botafogo é muito tempo na
parceria que pune bola jabulani bola só
que aí o que quer dizer que eu vou
buscar usar uma pistola mais pra frente
neto maluf falou se eu quero mais
rayfran o ato em um inventário e quioca
então o que nós temos aqui pessoal temos
filhos wheldon a gente tem aquela comida
que nós apoiamos a pouco temos o que
tanto tablóides com pizza substância
cronológico
o resto é um mapa na estamos um mapa 41
indicações tenho sete câmeras em sete
câmeras ao candidato que estiver então
as luzes vermelhas nos pontos de média
onde tem que colocar as câmeras
exatamente o que houve nesta e deve ser
outra alguns porque é exatamente olso
mesmo um gênio ok agora vamos ter que
colocar aqui uma câmera e não sei eu não
sei
há assim vai pronto já coloquei uma
pessoa por ela e outra aqui não é do
mato tem outra câmera vamos colocar aqui
outra onda cantar deve ser alguns numa
árvore não temos nem colocar nossa outra
câmera e isso até me ão que estamos a
andar no meio do futuro ou o monte fuji
este não fugiu
vamos ter que colocar uma câmera aqui é
quem já é pai anda a já conseguiu cair
mais uma quebra e agora meu foco das
câmeras agora vamos curar aqui floresta
nela e risco sinal a produção building
só cai tanto que tem buildings bild
estão lá mais próxima a 1
o horizonte acho que porque né nós
andarmos sempre em frente vamos
encontrar uma bíblia em que é isso que
vou fazer agora ó ramos pessoal e uma
quinta m1to será que tem um bicho e não
saibam explorar o estatut músico a fox
parece ser sempre igual à minha mãe fez
em casa 0 1 enviada fosse um urso
começasse a cair viajar fazer segundo
sujavam e é colher mais com um ferrari e
eu não percebo este o bom vamos entrar
aqui o que está em meu deus manhã a pele
preto pinto trip possui uma trilha joão
eu posso apanhar os valores com isso
hoje programa que eu não sair vamos
colocar uma armadilha é que irão para
sua própria preço viável o que acontece
o pesaro minha vida
mesmo assim eu caí não vou para fazer
estoque nunca faço isso nunca pisei em
armadilhas duas não vingar porque isto
eleva se o dispositivo eletrônico que
estipula uma luz no duro não sei o que é
isso para mim só reunirá virtual vejam
só ao fundo o que vocês vêem árvores
folhas por esta visitação ver p
agora parem só quando eu ligo binóculo
meu deus
desapareceram árvores e possui um lado
claro vamos ter muita calma muito
cuidado nesta hora por cá a coisa
malignas julieta por sentir que estou
sentindo o aroma do imóvel aqui no fundo
eu acho que o cinto demasiados jogos
porque pelo 5º andar já foi tempo começa
a ficar só por andar até que chegamos é
que nesta nova estrela ea exatamente eu
acho que nós vamos colocar uma câmera
aqui nesta área mas já não conseguimos
pôr mais por isso chávez já não fui eu
não fui eu vamos tentar
ae bruno é este thomson para o japão e
se expressa aquela parte quando você vê
um reunião e aparece com ela reservas do
patras vocês bulhão mesmo para ouvir
músicas e quando a música sacanagens
mortos quando a canaveses morte
assombrações
ok agora sou eu me pergunto onde é que
estão as coisas assustadoras
este está feliz mais tributado dinheiro
a um sol e boa aposta do preço justo não
estou neste caso tivesse mel
o ataque o barco a encontrar a pessoa
que encontrei foquem pistola anda com
isso eu já tenho uma não não tenho mais
uma pedra a psique palanque e psiquê
paula
meu deus ossos lei porém o idiota só
vais morrer em nó para mesmo texto no
plano tendo abandonado
será que é aqui que vai acontecer coisas
paranormais não porque esse jogo é uma
bosta
eu tenho que fazer com que marina eu
tenho duas pistolas agora 32 balas meu
deus agora já sou menina arms apelado
para lá do antes que precisei e as
noites o o osa também o cab que eu não
percebi isto antes agora sim estado no
âmbito pessoal agora é quando henrique
vai torcer pois também espera também
preparar a minha pistola espera eu vou
usar chocante porque isso é mais forte
eu acho é coberto pela mídia mais forte
olha aqui não sei que pessoas
concentrou-se eis a nossa equipe é só
uma pessoa né
era preciso usar as câmeras usar as
câmeras devem ser adquiridos também
alguns é que por dentro a equipe nesta
tua visão brutal dos destaques e
favorecem fredson tem câmera 11 número 2
não sei se consigo atrás das câmeras mas
eu vou tentar fazer isso porque um que
as câmeras muito juntos e eu acho que
não é preciso fazer isso não é bom tem
uma câmera que o fundo aabar controlado
eu eu consigo mexer nas câmeras brutal
caí câmera 5 nesta câmara esta câmera 5
já está a sentir uma dor enorme para um
público
meu deus que susto a cair aqui não há
nada demais
ouvi um barulho ai ai
na boca o som do yuck [ __ ] [ __ ]
kun
ae eu não consigo ver o rosto ao vivo as
forças pra [ __ ] meu dia hoje opera e
não morreu não reforça o coro por choque
quando soube que não sabe cantar de raps
aqui embaixo está aqui embaixo da lei
filha da [ __ ]
o botafogo vai para a fazer lhe uma nova
série eu estava falando com o novo eu
vou trazer o pessoal eu vou trazer o
metrô sofreu outra vaga vai aproveitar o
talento mata boa
vai daí love o topo pa está muito escuro
não consiga [ __ ] nenhuma
não eu tava só pesquisados por esta
ajuda é que não faço de espera pelo
primeiro vai passar rápido rápido rápido
ficou pela câmera da câmara aponta só
aponta sua pistola ponta só ep sublinha
henrique agora pode chover ainda anda se
o chupa-cabra anda anda que é que chupa
cabra agora quebrou a filha da mãe anda
com um barulho de tiro na cabeça e está
internada cabeça mas chama morreu o
pessoal não chega porque este vídeo mil
todo suado tive que uma hora e tal jogar
esta [ __ ] do jogo para tentar apanhar o
henrique eo batom com uma simples
pancada mas mesmo assim espero que vocês
tenham gostado este ano foi considerada
por vocês e foi por isso que o jogo não
é eu gostei isso globo é para tentar
apanhar o chupa cabra é isso pessoal
quando o aspecto brito fica bahia até a
próxima